fabrice di vizio bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous alors tout d'abord
qu'est-ce qui est ressorti lors de ses
positions lorsqu'il ressorti de ces
auditions c'est d'abord le sentiment
d'être écouté et pris au sérieux
les trois médecins ont été une audition
qui a duré longtemps et qui a été
interrompue à cause de l'emploi du temps
de l'un d'entre eux et qui a été déjà
date a été pris au 1er octobre pour
qu'ils se revoient et une cour une
chambre de l'instruction qui a manifesté
son désir de faire la vérité d'aller
jusqu'au bout ça leur a été dit que rien
ne sera laissé de côté
voilà sans préjuger du tout de la
culpabilité qui que ce soit il y avait
une recherche véritable de la vérité est
que les moyens nécessaires seraient
déployés donc c'est quand même très
bonnes nouvelles déjà alors justement je
vais vous citer vous avez des cars à nos
confrères du jdd ces témoignages
pourront aider la cour de justice de la
république à comprendre la vérité de
quelle vérité par les roues bien de la
vérité du terrain de la caisse qui s'est
passé réellement parce que si vous
voulez la vérité c'est un mot compliqué
dans cette affaire parce que en
permanence vous avez eu à faire et c'est
une constante à des gens qui vous ont
menti sur toute la durée de l'épidémie
ce plus particulièrement dans sa phase
aiguë et donc les miens mes clients
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
ils ont déposé plainte parce qu'à un
moment donné il y avait une déclaration
officielle est ce que je vivais sur le
terrain et il avait ce désir d'être
entendu on l'avait demandé dans la
commission denquête ce qui avait été
rejetée et il avait ce désir et elle
être entendu et pour le coup hier nous
avons trois magistrats trois hauts
magistrats quand même quand on pourrait
se dire qu'il avait mieux à faire qui
les ont entendus qui les ont écoutés et
qui donc sont désireux de cette
recherche de la vérité du terrain
je veux c'était une fois encore vous
avez déclaré que c'est la première fois
que la cour de justice de la république
se penche sur la question de la
responsabilité pénale de ministres en
pleine crise sanitaire
quel signal cela envoie t-il au
gouvernement mais le signal que ça 2
envoyé au gouvernement parce que j'ai
l'impression que aucun signal net envoyé
aux gouvernements de toutes façons que
ce gouvernement fait comme si ils
étaient seuls au monde et que rien
n'existe et autour le signal que ça
devrait leur envoyer c'est qu' il serait
peut être temps maintenant de considérer
que le temps de l'irresponsabilité est
terminé et qu'ils auront à répondre de
la gestion de cette crise et que ce
n'est certainement pas un an faisant
trop ou en faisant effectivement
n'importe quoi comme ils sont en train
de faire en ce moment que ils vont
échapper à leurs responsabilités que
gérer crise sanitaire ça demande une
transparence et sa demande effectivement
une adéquation entre les mesures
sanitaires et les libertés individuelles
sa demande de s'appuyer sur le réseau
sanitaire est manifestement le problème
c'est qu'il n'en prend pas le chemin le
gouvernement donc en cela cette
instruction aujourd'hui ouverte est une
bonne chose
alors vous êtes l'avocat de ce collectif
justement d'un point de vue pénal
concours edouard philippe alias busan et
olivier ferrand alors ce qu'ils
encourent
c'est une peine d'emprisonnement à
priori maintenant c'est ce que dit texte
en tout cas maintenant on va se faire un
pas se mentir
ne rêvons pas à la cour de justice de la
république mon dieu et la cour de la
cour pénale la plus clémente de l'état
est la cause la plus clémente de tout le
système judiciaire en ce que vous avez
un taux impressionnante dispense de
peine mais l'objectif est pas là et mes
clients l'ont rappelé d'ailleurs hier
ils ont eu cette phrase d'introduction
7,7 parole d'introduction disons on
n'est pas là on veut pas de la prison
pour les ministres ce qu'on veut nous
c'est la vérité et on veut qu'ils
reconnaissent ou que quelqu'un les
oblige à retrouver quelqu'un de
reconnaissent qu'ils ont mal agi et
qu'ils ont mis en danger volontairement
finalement les praticiens nous sommes
dernière question alors vous vous lavez
dès le 1er octobre d'autres auditions
avant avoir lieu avoir lieu quelles sont
les mesures que l'on est en droit
d'attendre à lissieu justement de ces
auditions de nouvelles lois la mise en
place de nouveaux dispositifs
je pense surtout que l'institution
judiciaire elle fonctionne de manière
indépendante
si vous voulez de la situation
législative je crois aujourd'hui que
finalement ce qui va être important
c'est que la cour travail si possible à
temps plein sur cette question
d'ailleurs les magistrats ont déploré un
par exemple de ne pas être dépêchée à
temps plein et de ne pas être déchargés
de leurs autres fonctions pour pouvoir
traiter cet épineux dossier
mais ce qu'on peut surtout attendre et
moi ce que j'attends en tout cas est ce
qu'on va demander c'est naturellement
des perquisitions mais il faut qu'on ait
des perquisitions au sein des différents
ministères pour que l'on sache qui
faisait quoi qui savait quoi et quand
merci beaucoup
fabrice di vizio d'avoir répondu à mes
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat des trois praticiens entendu par
la cour de justice de la république